Oh,
everybody like you,
you know,
you look good by the way.
Thanks.
Does a could not.
Lennox has seen me since I was 147 pounds.
Really?
You were 147 pounds at one point in time.
That was when I first started boxing.
I was one 47 how old were you?
15 oh,
okay.
I met him probably when I was 16 Oh really?
Yeah.
You guys have known each other that long.
Yeah,
I know his parents.
Yeah.
Wow.
And his and his mom and his brothers.
Every,
wow.
It goes back,
we're deep creek.
You don't realize that.
It was like,
you know,
I see him as a big star now.
I seen the movies and commercials rescuing people,
you know what I mean?
I'm like,
Yo,
this is the kid,
you know,
at least he's grown up.
He's like literally,
literally just selling mix tapes in the nineties he was already world champ and
I'd be playing the mix tape.
Yo Send me that and I'm like,
I just made it.
He's like,
I'll give you 20 bucks.
I'm like,
you just made $100 million.
Can you give me 100 bucks?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
everybody was making tapes back then.
Those days when people are aggressively trying to sell tapes on the streets.
I wasn't even trying to sell it.
I was just playing it in my car and he was like,
Yo.
So he got,
he had the new shit going on,
you know,
that was,
he had the real shit.
So I had to get a good it,
I didn't,
I didn't have that contact to get the music,
so he had the music context.
A lot of people don't know Russell's a legit Dj.
I reluctantly gave me what's mix tapes.
Reluctantly.
Yeah,
it's a good move.
Um,
when you know,
when you see him wrestling with people on Tmz,
you see that shit where the medicine,
what the jewel.
He's trying to
see what happened after.
He didn't throw no punches.
Go good kid.
His neck,
if you watch it,
you see,
I went for his arm to pull down to get his neck and then the other guy in front
of him pulled him down and I couldn't get the neck.
Could you tell us what happened?
I mean explain what happened.
All I seen was a guy walking out and you grab them.
No,
if you're watching it.
Okay,
so here's what happened.
Let me tell you what happens.
I'm there looking at a ring,
right?
Yeah.
And that guy sitting down earlier had checked to see if the door was open.
He went out to spit and now he really,
he thinks the door's open.
So now he thinks he's just going to get up and walk away with this ring.
This is where he makes his little move and then they lock the doors and then I'm
standing there,
I'm like,
what's going on?
And I'm like,
he takes a swing at my friend's father and then I go,
no,
no.
I tried to get his neck and that guy pulls him.
You see there's a lot of opportunities yet the neck there.
So no,
but I'm trying.
He's a big strong fucking guy and tonight you got to go over the top.
I will look,
I'm just trying,
but I had three layers on.
I'm not going to jacket a sweatshirt and a long sleeve shirt on.
There is an issue.
And then a,
so then I tried to go for the arm,
but everybody sees everybody's in my way.
So I'm like,
give me the arm.
Just let me get the eye move,
Dad,
move dad.
That's uncle David and their it guy.
I got the arm at the backward based.
Now we're pushing the arm down and you'll see I locked the rest here.
As soon as I locked the army says,
he says,
okay,
I want you to stop some living.
Right there it goes.
Okay.
Yeah,
I got the rest of the,
see the a little wrist lock,
Steven Seagal style.
And that was my friend.
Senpai shall look.
Oh,
there you go.
Rinse locks are legit.
He got up again.
No,
no,
no.
This is just a different angle.
A different,
I want to know what,
how far we was going to make with a ring.
You see,
um,
see that wall where my cousin is hiding?
Yeah.
When he was trying to get out,
he whacked his head against that wall.
Oh No.
And uh,
and he could as he,
her open the thief.
Yeah.
So whatever happened to him,
he got arrested.
He was this in Toronto?
No New York City.
No Shit.
Right in the jewelry district.
So it's fun.
That's like ill planned out move.
Do you know that?
They know that people grab things and run away?
Well there's that and he apparently this guy had been coming to the store for
six months scoping,
scoping the place out.
Oh that's hilarious.
Cocked it up poorly.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Just silly.
Do you have to go to quarter or anything?
But I don't know.
I haven't heard anything since.
Do you want,
and I just put them in.
All I was trying to do is hold them there cause right.
All the doors were locked.
I'm like it doesn't make sense again to a scrap but the guy,
if I could just put him in a choke hold or,
or a lock then till the cops come.
But the thing is like you could injure him.
If you enjoy him then they suit you.
Well yeah,
not really.
As ridiculous as it sounds.
It's rough work.
Well Russell is not really a law enforcement officer.
I could see if you had,
nobody would have been dangerous for everybody in the store if he was running
wild.
True.
Yeah.
So I mean,
look,
he's lucky he didn't crack them.
Yeah.
You know,
I just locked him up and I said,
all right,
as soon as I locked him up,
he goes,
okay.
And I go,
okay,
good.
And then he had one knee,
one knee down and one leg up and that kicked that leg out.
So he would,
we'd be blown both knees get rid of his base.
Yes.
Right.
I was trying to move as bay.
Who's the big,
I've got a question.
Okay.
Now if the whole thing happened again,
how would you do things different?
I would have told everybody get out of my way so I can get him in a choke.
And would you just put them asleep?
Yeah,
just put them to sleep.
Lay him down,
let him down,
talk him in and he went back home.
And obviously you feel good about yourself.
Did you kind of run the whole thing through your mind a couple of times?
Like,
Yo,
this could have happened or what could happen.
I started thinking after if he had a gun or if he had a knife,
but I'm like,
if he had a gun,
he would have pulled it out right away.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's,
you know,
he's not here to surprise you with a gun.
He's here to scare you with the gun.
Well,
if there's all that many dudes on them too,
good luck pulling that gun out.
Yeah.
One of us would've got shot,
but,
but probably not food or something that.